hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to The Escapist - now it's
been a long time since I played the
escapists and if you remember I wasn't
any sort of good at it but now with the
sequel in beta and this is a very early
access build of it by the way but now
that it's in beta I'm gonna try to be
rude there's vs. holy [ __ ] there's
leaderboards holy [ __ ] there's a
criminal record
my characters oh my god I get to make
characters I'm gonna name you bumbo oh
you're gonna have a that face you're
gonna have this color you're gonna have
a oh bum ba-bum ba-bum bow oh bombuh
oh I just realized I'm making bumble
myself Bombo with this smile at gold is
that even a smile oh there he is
I guess you're not bumble anymore your
mark mark your mark come bow her combos
a bad name mark come bow ain't the name
that you normally want to go with when
you're making a character but uh you
know what it is it is what it is well
we're off to a great start with more
come bow over there all right how about
frump t'en your frump din all right cool
ah hell yeah Trumpton oh yeah get it
from frumpy Oh from thin I'll front in
my man now I liked it better when you
were before from damoff romped in Oh
prompting oh hell yeah frontin are you
gonna be AB I'd like to think that the
name is inspired by the character that I
make and this guy's not asked backwards
this guy is lumple - hey how you doing I
like to end my names and tons you know
what I'm saying all right let me make
the face first oh yeah that's good okay
alright this is uh this is uncle kunkel
this is uncle Kong cool everybody say
uncle uncle there got flu we get this is
terrible flu I like it's terrible fool
you're good this is cactus Kaggle this
kegglemeister tagoma Pagal must
goddamnit hey go mum Fleur that's Kaggle
mum Fleur this is this
this is griller e your your crunkle but
Wamsley and ah Steve so we got mark
combo from Dan plumb Bolton uncle
compass dermal flu kaggle muffler
griller e crunkle but Wamsley and Steve
and that's my team God that took way too
long but all right so again I'm not a
hundred percent good at this game
because I'm not patient but I'm going to
go at this with the most intelligence
that I can possibly go through and hope
for the best
Oh fresh with the basics Wow who needs
to do that I certainly do not I need to
introduce myself with everybody here new
game that's so cool you can play with
other people oh that's awesome
Santa Burt's 2.0 is the first proper
prison however the guards won't let you
have everything your own way is a
challenging game follow the yellow arrow
to attend routines and keep a low
profile explore the prison well keep a
lookout for any weaknesses find the
materials you need to craft the tools
for your escape try and keep your heat
and security level low to avoid trouble
from the guards the most straightforward
way of escaping is breaking through the
prison's border for example you might
tunnel the chip or cut your way out good
luck uh where's my guys where's my guys
well there's where's my guys hey hey
come on now where's my guys oh where I
just a chomps fiefs Staz Tech it grows
echoes my guys I didn't just spend all
that time making my guys just for you to
toss them out to the wind like that
alright fine
wow these guys all look sad I think I'll
go with this one everyone seems to look
saddened downtrod except for these for
you guys here oh they woke up oh look at
them all I don't care alright let's go
into this don't know where more combo
end but we're from Bolton God where's
Gregory where's Steve oh here there's my
guys Oh mark combo from Dan Pompton Yong
Guk uncle ster fabu Kaggle muffler
griller eeee
that one doesn't exist apparently
Wamsley Steve what's wrong with this one
[ __ ] all right mark combo get in
here mark combo what's it do
welcome to central perks two point oh
you Rio I'm stuck here alright cool
great what did I do roll call is
mandatory gray the prison will lock down
if you are not present the food served
in our canteen is a great source of
health and energy great cool escape
dance will be reported to our control
room great okay alright then increase
your intelligence by reading our books
great I like that that sounds good
thanks for the tour by the way like it
and use the gym equipment to increase
your strength and speed that does you
see that that way it does burn some
money by visiting our job offices
officers alright cool
we will allocate one of these rooms for
you to stay in all right
sweet digs it's a pretty nice duds as
you can see we have a film crew with us
for a while please don't interrupt their
filming I would never I would never
hello everybody my name is markiplier
out there uh Obama's join the game
that's so cool you can play multiplayer
with people oh hey wake up hey [ __ ]
as all wait okay there we go yep alright
hello I'm here lens and pop oh boy
random searches this seems fair mark
cumple more combo don't like this or
combo ain't too happy about this view oh
wow excuse you are you guys so rude
you're duh oh jeez hey hey how's it
going there Bubba jeez
yeah this place is brutal more brutal
than I remember it being hmm showing off
my mug when so many blunts out of me
no idea where he landed we see let me
know what I don't know what that fine
man's Ezio's mug okay
that sounds good mmm teabag sock duct
tape yep okay mug
I found a mug I didn't find the muddy
guard in Covent Garden coming boy
anybody else got some good stuff around
here anybody else got some good stuff
hey yeah good stuff that I can stuff in
my hey that's contraband but I like it
alright alright alright okay let's see
what else we on your screwdriver bottle
of aftershave Oh box is a tiny box cream
that guys probably gonna come up with
this way because I got I got a nail file
on me and I don't want to lose you wait
let's get those in there I think those
are contraband so there's got to be
hidden away nice and safe Lake alright
got some goodies wait whatever oh wait
was just a mug oh well that's the mug oh
where do I bring that to oh okay alright
alright man there's a lot of free time
they give us a man Zito and and always
upstairs where's even an upstairs around
here
okay any day now okay thank you oh man
Xena's about to come down
Manzi no Manziel man zero buddy hey I
got money in and reputation
okay well man see Oh Minzy no oh this is
sad I don't need to eat so I guess I'm
fine but let's see what everybody else
wants
hey Ely it's constant past now I'm okay
don't want to beat anybody up ain't this
wall blocking their desk Anala noms okay
interesting
well I'm just gonna go off and plant a
brick in somebody's desk ale nobody
minds hello sir more combo on the way
nobody mind mark combo mark combo don't
mind you so don't mind mark combo or a
job time well I don't have a job why
don't I have a job at all okay all right
let's see put this in there oh no oh no
I don't even need a wall why do I have
that out in the open
oh god I didn't want to put the oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] duck [ __ ] okay we're fine
everything's good hey officers I'm not
dawdling what are you dawdling about hey
da diliman are you going Donnell boys
you think I'd be dawdling do you know me
you know how I Donnell you know my
dawdling ways days are over
get moving I don't know where where
would I'm oh I need to move over there
okay whoops
sorry sorry guys sorry sorry sorry sorry
sorry sorry
I'm moving I'm moving I'm moving I am
moving EEE EEE
all right I'll find a job
[Music]
you have to attend the job office when
you don't have a job speaking to the job
office staff will reward you with money
this is awkward why you're just an idiot
that was my boy thank you thank you for
that I feel so good all right what's up
next
exercise time oh yeah all right this is
oh hey puppies poochie's moochers I've
got a poacher's out there oh that's good
though well good to know fit it over
ah got it
what oh that's so cool oh look at me oh
look at me oh like a face okay goodbye
alright well that's interesting let's
shower up before everybody else ah
that's a good stuff I'm not quite naked
but you know it's that the thought that
counts oh wait I'm already showering you
fools oh you thought you got me but you
didn't yeah yeah you don't got me you
never got me all right well excuse me
officer I don't know whose desk this is
a Gabe oh okay all right all right
I prolly so dad I don't even know any
anymore I don't have any crafting skills
Italy D aftershave sheet of metal
[ __ ] yeah I'll take that alright I'm
pretty full up I got to go back and dump
some contraband because I am walking in
trouble who what could I make poster
manicure kit that's good oh alright but
I need to learn I need to learn a thing
or two where do I go to learn that's
what I was looking for it was upstairs
somewhere wasn't it I more to learn this
place here can you teach me something
who are you Hillary what are you doing
here teach me I want to learn I'm here
to learn is this solitaire what is this
that's some good stuff but I don't think
I got enough room for that until I got
more till I know what I'm going for I
just need to learn there could be your
friend please no thank you I don't want
that that's Suns awful oh oh I needed to
be at dinner time oopsies oopsie boobsie
[Music]
ah I see oh oh intelligence is flowing
through me I'm so smart now look how
smart my big brain is how they think
this is difficult they didn't go to
Harvard like I did Harvard I am very
tired
nope too tired I got a shower son girl
not tired and such such as the like as
that can I give shower shower up no my
me he's late day shower
alright SCU's be I gotta say I really
like this it's it's a bit of an
improvement over what was before whoo
that is some good [ __ ] but I don't have
the money for right now is the good
stuff I'm gonna be so smart
I'm so smart right now you guys all gels
about smart I am
oh look at me god it's so brilliant at
brains mark combo ain't never seen
nobody no smarter than mark combo is
what I'm trying to say ah dude ah piss
and vinegar I could really do with the
rest can I go take a nap can I take a
nap is that something I can do and I
just lights out already I've had enough
of this [ __ ] this is not my bed
yeah sorry excuse me sorry I thought
that was my bad sorry very comfortable
though okay so there's the vent system I
just need three more points and then I'm
up to sixty which is pretty much all I
really need right they made it a lot
easier to learn stuff which is kind of
nice that way you're not spending days
and days just eating your brain out
trying to learn occult I'm ready for
roll call I'm still ready for that hey
you want to give me whatever quest
you're talking about over there hey no I
didn't want to say I wanted to talk to
my buddy here my buddy chancer see no I
don't want a medic outfit now I Milo
weapons
I could probably locate makeshift spear
makes you spear holy [ __ ] that's a
that's a Doozer I'm getting a lot of
lower reputations is by turning
everybody down just don't think I can
get these things I'm returning to us no
oh my me I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm just
sleeping I'm sleeping it up so anyway
that is the escapists tube there's a lot
more to this game that I want to play
and it's really cool the improvements
that they made
I want to actually escape of my own
volition but I know it's gonna take me a
while to get there so I'm gonna play a
few more episodes of this and then
escape this prison so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]